my name is Donny to our joy by Chris
waters your back Danny I'm back it was
Alex new house yes i am still haven't
fired you uh well i know we have yes
he's just gotten rehired of yes okay
he's very resourceful I akshay is here
as well yeah I am and we're gonna play a
bunch of stupid diesel Stormers is there
some sort of stipulation as to if Alex
can get fired again today I mean sucks
so far we've managed to get into the
game cooperatively under his tutelage
shuts the Bears just under the wire real
close things are looking good for his
continued employment but uh I don't know
let's see what diesel Stormers is about
alright atop it is this is important
thing about being an intern hallux the
intern is that you need to you need to
prove your worth you need wow this is
your chance to do what we like to call
in the industry game demo ok so this is
an a this is your first video game demo
I'm the green video games com yes take
it away tell us about diesel store me
yeah so I'm those filled up and this is
a 2d shooter real um yeah with some
platforming and like hovering elements
and stuff and so as you see there's that
ball in the middle where all of us are
connected to and you can use that to
fling yourself about like around the map
wat bumper like that yeah and uh yeah
new um there's also some hovering and
some shooting and some enemies and
there's this goop stuff that opens I'm
screwing it up for everyone get up here
dan how do I jump hey hey and you can
hover and if you use lv then you'll
fling yourself through that ball and go
up to the other side yeah so as you see
there's a bunch of this goop there see
it water and brain scoop station I'm not
sure what those are yet cool Matilda
sweating the goop does slow you down if
it hits you so let's go kill this guy
alright we just walked through it
excellent yeah for Yahoo forget see him
later yeah so here's this you're
probably a good thing to blow up is the
Garrity what do we do it to goo you just
don't want to get touched by a piece of
slows you down a lot you're in the fire
whoever's green yeah Chris is green damn
I mean to say I'm on fire yeah you're on
fire so yeah so this this game is made
by developer that actually kick started
it back in May they're the same
developer though I
may yeah all right this is super early
that yeah all right that made giana
sisters oh you're kidding me yep yes i'm
a big john sisters fine yeah so they
made that gay made the best giana
sisters game yeah cuz those old ones
weren't too hot yeah they've started the
new the new giana sisters and they made
is a dreams the kick started this one as
well and achieve the goal obviously and
now they are about to release it into
steam early access two days from now
right yep two days from now also add
we're also giving away a bunch of codes
yeah on the show today 10 10 but instead
of doing it into usual just retweet
something malarkey we're actually that
is a marquee we're using this I think we
have a shot of it there is a robot made
of Lego at which part which has been
doing the rounds at Double Fine for the
past a couple of weeks it's currently
it's currently roaming the floor trying
to basically go up to these post-it
notes of your codes written on it's just
family it just family good you girls
know what there's that one right there I
had a code that people can use for this
for this video yeah and it's another ten
of them or no no there's no other yeah
one might 10-1 that was pretty cool that
was good timing who's controlling the
robot is it is it tim schafer no it's
not it's it's the internet the
collective internet it's twitch tell Val
you're basically go on to the tithe Inc
we've got an address for the twitch but
if you go on there and you can basically
type in forward left right or backwards
or back rather actually the lower lower
case yeah and it basically will i will
move that little bugger it's like twitch
plays pokemon but in physical form
that's pretty awesome mmm there's some
bad guys right here like this guy would
murder hablame arrest yeah so I found
that um actually dashing into them is
almost more effective than a gun
original yeah so I I generally just you
know dash a lot because that's that's
fun and clean here so there's also a big
like gun upgrade system yes in the game
yeah there's that it is it's the
developer describes it as actually like
a loop based shooter and so there is
quite a quite a bit of a one of these is
it almost dead is that me
should this go so he's dealing loot from
your other players down as well from
your buddies I don't know if you can do
that but there is loot to be found
throughout the world and you can upgrade
your gun with it there's actually pretty
pretty crazy gonna upgrade system
transport trans coop is still freaking
me your hands group not really sure what
that's where the part of the Lord works
comfort yes so on if you're if you're
standing on a platform you can jump down
through it just by holding down present
yet comes back one lesson I don't not
unless of the block oh Jesus Christ
again pulverized me and Chris again yeah
I'm going in here at people yeah yeah oh
yeah there's a possible summer yeah this
is single fare as well right yes not
have to play for people you do not see
were absolute the ball of single player
oh yeah um it's just it like I from what
I could tell it just gravitated towards
space or to those like four texts things
okay um but you can use the ball as like
a weapon as well right I've seen video
on I've gotta climb up here come on
let's do this yes oh [ __ ] look it up
there's a boss gap yeah because the idea
that we're all like siblings and this is
like the umbilical bowl that holds us
together yes tom yes yes so we want a
butter gun great yep sounds good neat
I'm down with it back to the hub world
this is good if anyone has any questions
I will do my best to play and also oh
yeah do something up there actually oh
let's see what this ends I mean is yeah
I can do single-player kind of that Ben
you gonna jump in I got a Tom doesn't
wanna sit around all right wall alright
do to free player I'll go get some
questions perfect are right okay uh you
guys can jump in now there we go all ye
no hard work cafe if you have any
questions gamespot shot twit shot as
ever yes so this is a very obviously in
very early access it's actually pretty
early access right now but i also want
to mention the developer is actually in
the child at the moment as well our good
question on stems wait ask him someone
asked him about if my umbilical theory
is right
oh we know it is Tom okay well oh my god
else could it be oh god I miss all up I
just got transported yep who's blue me
Alex yep on this marble job yeah it's a
collectible blue thing never mind I wish
we never bother already passed its he's
gobbling forget you you guys seem to
have pretty good healthy man we're all
right well uh there's really some weird
dad oh yeah so these these are when
things are pretty annoying yeah they'll
get you we get you oh you should blast
it Oh get you I don't you give it a
blast with a diesel storm and blast what
now to get it I don't see in the top
left corner dancing that's my health I
don't know if your guys health is this
your head number oh really yeah but
there's only two full health bars yeah
yeah so you have like four yeah for
health bars which like your armor and
that you can find things throughout the
throughout the levels that will increase
like what the light fill one bar all
right person i'm basically invincible
right now is we're gonna Pelt bars um
and we'd like jump off of the cnet
building we'd be fine yeah probably that
yes that makes sense i think that right
now the health is not a massive I don't
know I didn't feel like I was close to
dying but then again that is the
wonderful ready access titles yet that
is one of the the items that will fill
up on your health bars affinity the fish
out ass couldn't commit I had a
connection to the ball break is there
any problems that can occur if that
happens that it can break when one of us
falls in love with a another diesel
stormer and wants to move out yep so the
things like let stuff yeah oh yeah we
broke the ball and I just went
teleporting back to ya okay look like
top or back like the bottom and um we're
gonna go start a family I need to our
space so is that the main reason why it
exists you feel that there is there some
sort of combat requirement first I think
you predominantly paid the single-player
stuff yeah the first time I think go up
you just come and meet mechanika yeah
there are ways to like certainly fun to
zip around yeah
and yeah I like slipping around it like
doing out doing that a lot and if you if
you like the main mechanic I found with
that is that if you fling yourself into
enemies you can knock them off and knock
them into fire pits or you know into
spikes or something like that but i'm
not sure if there's any direct combat
associated with it have you seen any
more upgrades in relation to the
movement stuff or is it predominantly
the gun i was predominantly the gun from
what i can tell you got to feel me when
you play this because you've got yours
we've done single player on coop as well
that this is a game best played other
people if you dig like um is it's pretty
chaotic in coop the camera is a lot more
finicky top it looks like which is I
think something that the developers are
addressing i think that the you can you
can more control where that we're that
like all in the middle is the umbilical
ball where you can fling around you can
better control that in single player but
i think that when i play it is a lot
more fun with more people it's just it's
just wild and i'm pretty crazy the wild
incorrect yes yeah guys I figured out
you can just hold down the shoot button
and shoot all the time yeah there's a
cool down though I'm one of them right
when I was playing it was like once
every second or so fire popped off uh I
mean you can't let it it's not rapid
fire
question
oh yeah see that that's where oh wow are
you diesel storming right now yes oh
well what are you doing so if you get
enough of these muscle [ __ ] balls if you
collect enough them and you can you can
ask me this and it is diesel strong it's
basically a little storm going yet my
gosh you guys get all the diesel store
that crispy yeah yeah he's a scam I felt
like I center 8 everyone who you who you
touching it's also shield oh and then
they're bomb shell prob like that I
don't care about bounds and Diesel's a
woman ya think I'm family oh my god I
just all right there's a nobody likes a
bragger Chris the sauce all right this
guy's awake not like the last time so
you gotta put in the arts here got it
yeah and then the death of really pulled
the yards we did it put in the yard put
them in when we got an engine and a
brown card yes a bright a Brian card
yeah that's one of the top three types
of the card ticket Alex new house yeah
congratulations you can stay here
another week swim you can stay here and
do work we look for that performance ran
it up precious diesel stormers when is
it available where people where can
people get it how much will it cost you
even do you know that I don't know the
price okay I it wasn't on their own age
so it's available in two days on Steam
early access um yeah that's it looks
pretty cool so number is that a 10 score
out of 10 oh my god for me here yeah
sure Tom I was gonna say all right
actually no you go first her kin z okay
we're we don't given yeah I was gonna go
Theo she's head ok fair enough yes
you